a new massive organized caravan of
migrants storming through a blockade of
mexican security forces look at that as
they make their way north toward the
united states thomas feely is a former
ice field office director for buffalo
new york and he joins us now to react
good morning to you thomas
good morning aj how are you doing well
this doesn't surprise you does it we
don't expect them to follow the law
no it doesn't and you know as long as
the door remains open they'll continue
to come and what's really shocking about
this caravan is they're already
demonstrating that they don't obey the
laws of where they're currently at so
there's no expectation that there'll be
our laws when they get here what happens
when they do get here
well the only response that i'm aware of
by dhs is to detail people to the border
from ice and cbp but they're not there
to stop it or close the border or do any
type of law enforcement action
they're only there to help process these
people and get them into the country
quicker so
i i don't i don't know what dhs is doing
i don't know where our vice president is
but obviously uh an open border is what
they wanted and it's an open border is
what they got they're complaining
because they're seeking asylum and
they're saying their applications are
not being processed and all of the
appointments are full they're heading to
mexico city we're being told about 4 000
of them do you expect them i mean
they're carrying american flags they're
wearing biden t-shirts and holding up
biden signs they're heading for the u.s
aren't they
yeah i i i can't wait to see if any of
them there uh wear let's go brandon
shirts because that'd be really funny
but yeah they're gonna they're gonna
keep coming um as long as the border
remains open and unsafe to all of us
here in this great country they're gonna
keep coming and they're going to keep
coming and they're going to keep coming
where's the leadership we're not seeing
kamala harris going down there anymore
joe biden has never been down there what
about the head of ice or the head of cbp
what do you know about them
well they're both unqualified for their
positions in my opinion they were both
chiefs of police which you know as
honorable as that is that does not
prepare you to lead one of the largest
law enforcement agencies in the country
both of them have backgrounds in being
anti-ice and pro-open border so you know
this is just a tragedy that's going to
keep playing out and this is by design
this is what this administration wants
and you know as far as a lack of
leadership you know people are asking
why aren't they at the border because
this is going exactly as planned by them
so there's no reason for them to go down
there it's really sad that morale is low
and uh cbp and ice are just getting
their butt kicked every day why why
aren't we seeing kamala harris going
back down there she's heading to paris i
know in november and many people are
scratching their heads saying we need
her to stay here and deal with what's
happening on the border
well if you think about it he's this is
what she wants this is all by design so
she really doesn't have a need to go to
the border because
she's not going to go down there and you
know rally against her own
administration's policies this is what
they wanted and you know now she's going
to go over to france i believe maybe he
has some tea and crumpets in england
stop over say hi to everybody over there
but this is just ridiculous some
madelines and macaroons right thank you
so much for being on with us thomas
you're right hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now